behind every sleek innovation is the
messiness of creation it seems an
interesting concept a team is a
cross-functional group of people diverse
often distributed and they come together
to solve complex problems at Atlassian
we want to build small nimble agile
teams teams that are autonomous who are
empowered and can run fast but we have
to equip them with some techniques that
enable them to do that one of our values
here is around being an open company and
our tools are also built to be open so
we embrace openness and everything that
we do when you trust each other and you
build that trust over time you really
can do great work Trust is like oxygen
you only realize it's not there when
it's gone it's so important for teams to
build trust so they can help understand
each other how to work together we want
to give teams the tools the practices
the techniques to be functional teams to
work across Chios to embrace diversity
and to do the best work of our life
every single day at Atlassian whilst we
write code we don't ship code we ship
experiences and products part of
bringing that to life is our design team
you use their creative juices their
knowledge their experience to bring our
products to life and to give our
customers and seamless experiences the
team playbook was built by teams four
teams originally a concept that we built
internally so that we could help us
teams understand how they work together
it's comprised of two main aspects the
first one is a health monitor at all
that our teams use to assess how they
work together second part are planes
these are exercises that our teams can
do together to improve their muscle
their mental muscle so that they can
improve the way they work so things like
sparring are all about them being able
to interact with each other push each
other to raise the bar in early up their
game diverse range of experience so
we're able to kind of bounce ideas off
of each other plays like a project
poster and then an event like a project
kickoff are absolutely essential for
establishing trust and context across
the entire team because we have these
tools we can be open with each other and
honest with each other
and build that level of trust that not a
lot of teams have we are able to work
through projects faster ship projects
faster and really just everything comes
out at a higher quality so what we found
when teams use a playbook is they
prevent instead of cure they spend more
time looking at the future and
understanding what can go wrong in the
team and so they can solve those
creative challenges every single day and
when you have the entire team aligned on
what you're trying to do you're going to
deliver something that's so much better
than what any one person could work on
the trust within our team hasn't only
grown but also the trust within the
company has grown for our department
people believe in us more they want to
work with us more because we are now
taking the initial ask and really
raising it to a whole new level whilst
the world celebrates individual
accomplishments really its teams that
come together to achieve the great
things so we want to help those teams
work together and do the best work of
their life
we have great minds and we have great
tools if we can find those things with
amazing practices we can solve any
problem